voici tel qu'on l'enseigne sur les bords
du gange l'ase hanau posture du lion
spécialement destiné à calmer l'individu
et à refouler la gaule est début des
années 50 une pratique arrive en france
le yoga il s'agit d'une discipline
nouvelle que ce journaliste de 1950
trouve plutôt original tenez cher
monsieur vous qui accumule les soucis et
tracas
souvenez-vous de lyon
[Musique]
années 60 je ris mais chez le premier
professeur de hatha yoga en france
il ouvre de nombreuses écoles et insiste
sur l'universalité de la pratique
tout le monde peut adapter là je n'ai
pas uniquement réservées pour les
hindous le gars va se démocratiser en
occident grâce à quelques stars
mondiales le beatles par exemple en 1968
il passe deux mois dans l'ashram de
richy qu ils ont rencontré le mari chi
ils ont été conquis et l'ont rejoint
avec leurs épouses dans sa retraite de
rishikesh au cachemire en france dès
1963 il y a même des démonstrations de
louga sur les plateaux télé et moi aussi
j'ai besoin de me décontracter avec ses
envies tout à l'heure je vais essayer de
me décontracter un petit peu la tca au
moins deux micros sur la tête
[Applaudissements]
avec la mouvance hippie dans les années
soixante dix la discipline continue de
progresser
bizot je crois que c'est une famille à
quelqu'un de soi-même permanence et que
comme motivation principale
il y as au départ talus forme limitée
aujourd'hui le yoga c'est 2,6 millions
d'adeptes en france 300 millions à
travers le monde il fait partie du top 5
des sports les plus pratiqués
[Musique]